it's been a while I think it will just  see science yeah I think I think it's  not a mistake here to just call it quits  because  obviously I think that like everybody  knows I think that and it did design a  great gameplay Champion Magnus Carson  yeah nicely done by Magnus starting from  the from the decision to play C6 here to  not enter any of the theoretical lines  uh you know avoid all of the discussion  of the kind of a very very safe kind of  boring Asian games which you'll never  ever win with black  and uh  yeah here after Bishop G5 the decision  to play B5 Bishop 2 Rook E8 very calmly  also uh an important kind of teachable  moment for people who may have not seen  this structure before  playing E5 looks like it's an active  move you know you're doing something  with your life but it's actually very  very beneficial to why it because it  makes it much harder for black to